sri lanka's prime minister says his
country is now bankrupt and that there's
no immediate end to the current economic
crisis sri lankans are facing hardships
on many fronts petrol supplies have
dried up because foreign currency
reserves to pay for fuel imports have
run out prices have soared with food
inflation now running at about 57
annually more than two-thirds of sri
lankan households say they're eating
less as a result schools and offices are
currently closed to keep people off the
streets people are angry and frustrated
and they're blaming politicians for the
crisis especially president gotta bayer
rajapaksa and his family which dominate
politics
prime minister ranil vikremi singer
informed parliament of sri lanka's
insolvency on tuesday he said the
economic crisis would be around until at
least the end of next year he added that
bailout talks with the imf depended on
finalizing a debt restructuring plan
with creditors in the coming weeks
here's more of his remarks to lawmakers
our country has held talks with the imf
on many occasions before
but this time
the situation is different
from all those previous occasions
in the past we have held
we are now participating in the
negotiations
as a bankrupt country
therefore we have to face a more
difficult and complicated situation than
previous negotiations
let's go now to colombo and speak to
journalist marlon arisinger welcome to
dw news asia
the government says sri lanka is now
bankrupt why is it bankrupt and and how
much worse can it get
hi thank you for having me
yeah i think it's uh safe to say that uh
we've hit
rock bottom uh but with every passing
day it feels like we are uh you know
thinking even further so it's more of an
economic i guess like an economic debt
spiral
um how did we get here you know that's
been discussed extensively over the uh
last few months and uh you know we have
also become like a caution tale or like
a horror story to other countries
in brief the main causes are
corruption
severe economic mismanagement
political incompetence and arrogance and
misguided policies you know like the um
overnight uh chemical fertilizer ban
last year um which is why uh in addition
to all these crises um i mean we also
have a a looming food crisis to look
forward to and you know currently you
know i'm uh i'm experiencing power cut
right now so uh
this is the state of things or state of
affairs right now in sri lanka
you've touched on it a bit there these
these stories of desperation and
suffering which is sort of veering into
a humanitarian crisis how is this
situation affecting people
yeah i mean you're right undeniably it
is a humanitarian crisis
there's a shortage of life-saving drugs
and medical equipment
the majority of small businesses have
completely closed down
you know even well-established
businesses
informal workers and
daily wage earners are undergoing
immense suffering um you know because of
skyrocketing inflation and as human
rights activists have pointed out in
addition to a humanitarian crisis this
has also turned into a human rights
crisis you know just a few hours ago uh
peaceful protesters were arrested and
i'm getting reports that even uh uh
you know about 20 minutes back uh
protesters were tear gassed right so uh
and just a few days ago we had uh a
footage of an army officer kicking a
citizen at a fuel ship and this man was
not even a protester you know he was
just simply asking some questions so
over the and we see this kind of uh
incidents over the last few uh uh you
know of the last few weeks um or you
know of police police brutality and
armed forces brutality so it is a
humanitarian crisis as well as a human
rights crisis right now a human rights
crisis too people of course want to
weigh out the imf and the world bank
though are hesitant to come to the
rescue
of sri lanka why is that
well the prime minister actually
mentioned in parliament yesterday uh
that the first round of discussions with
the imf has been a success and
but the assistance depends on a debt
restructuring program
now the imf recently stressed that other
challenges are needed to be addressed
like
containing rising inflation
attending to the severe balance of
payments pressures
and uh reducing the country's
vulnerability to corruption so in in my
opinion there is a correlation between
the imf and political stability you know
dealing with corruption having a proper
plan um and assurance that the
government will stick to the conditions
of the of the imf deal once it's agreed
so these are some other challenges i
think uh uh which we are facing uh when
it comes to the agreement uh with imf
lots of challenges that you've outlined
there people in sri lanka say this this
situation why the country is in this
situation is the fault of the powerful
and dominant rajapaksa family why are
they getting the
blame well uh the rajapaksa family has
been often labeled uh as a family
business and if you go back to uh
rajabaksha's presidential campaign in
2019
a kind of a you know i like a highly
mythicized figure was created you know
the the the
political slogan was badakarana
which means the war hero that works so
the waters were very optimistic of a
systems change but then it was evident
that the family just picked up where
they left off in 2015 anger started
building up and which eventually
developed into the current slogans which
is gohan quota and go home rajapaksas um
i think people now see that the
decisions that were taken by the
president votable rajabaksha uh pm and
finance finance minister uh mahindra
rajapaksa and then basil rajasthan who
was also a finance minister for a short
time
have led to the current prices so this
is why the the people are blaming the
raja doctor
there are some big regional players here
of course that that being india and
china what have they promised or or what
have they had to say about the crisis in
sri lanka
well um officially both china and india
have been affirming their support to uh
for sri lanka and they have helped
through credit lines for fuel donations
of medicine and
dry rations and food in the in the past
couple of months
and
when it comes to india this is in line
with
pm modi's neighborhood first policy
and from india there have been donations
but over 300 million uh sri lankan
rupees that were given to sri lanka uh
and in addition this is in addition to
the usd 3.5 billion economic assistance
that they have provided
in entrances so um
when it comes to china uh china has also
been helping and recently uh you know
china even placed uh the indian
government for
uh its ongoing support to sri lanka and
they also assured
their commitment to help sheila
that was journalist marlon arie singer
in sri lanka we thank you very much for
your time
thank you
[Music]
well climate change is threatening food
production around the world and is
predicted to push millions of people
into poverty one region in central india
is seeing this right now farmers there
are getting into terrible debt partly
because of crop losses caused by
irregular weather patterns and it's
driving many to suicide dw's manira
children has more from the region of
vidarbha
there are days when geeta chaudhary
can't hold back her tears
she lost her husband bhanu das two years
ago
he took poison
the reason
a debt of rupees 150 000
just a little more than 1800 euros
he was a farmer
and he took a loan for farming which he
could not pay back
i never thought he could take such a
step and go away before he took his life
he used to be tense irritable he used to
keep to himself and the day he took his
life he said nothing at all to anyone
now takes care of the farm with the help
of her son
she says things have become more
difficult since panudas died
she is not alone in her grief
in the past decades tens of thousands of
farmers most of whom sowed cotton
have taken their lives in the vidarba
region of central india
this area has come to be called the
graveyard of farmers
farmers often have to borrow money to
buy seeds and fertilizer crop failures
or poor yield means they cannot pay the
money back
they fall into a cycle of debt and
misery
they say they're not getting enough
support from the government
harish pagath a farm activist and a
farmer himself is trying to help
he says the cost of cultivation is
increasing
at the same time erratic monsoon rains
and the bakeries linked to climate
change are adding to the farmer's
day distress day a farmer's debt keeps
increasing he starts feeling depressed
after that he begins to question why
he's alive if he is not able to properly
nourish
and educate his children
depression well
her husband died by suicide in 2015
unable to pay back his farm debt of
rupees 50 000 or about 600 euros
nobody should go through what i faced my
children suffered they couldn't complete
the education
while kanta got some financial help from
the government
most do not manage to get the meager
state compensation to families of
farmers who die by suicide
i had to struggle a lot i went to the
authorities multiple times for the
compensation but they kept refusing
gita regrets that her husband did not
talk to her in detail about his
financial problems
maybe she could have helped
her hopes and ambitions are not pick
now she just wants to survive so she can
bring up her son